January 2012 the GOI one satellite
photographs a strange oval formation in
a wilderness of ice analysis of the
image measures the concentric ovals at
four hundred feet wide archaeologist
Marc Alta wheel takes a closer look the
kind of thing that when you see almost
anywhere in the world you say
immediately it definitely is man-made
the rings of the structure looked like
the walls of some sort of compound like
something that's been designed we're in
the middle of the Antarctic so what in
the world is that doing there the image
comes from one of the most remote
untouched regions on earth the vast
frozen deserts of East Antarctica this
is in the middle of nowhere one of the
most inhospitable terrain on the planet
it's the coldest driest windiest place
on earth it's thousands of miles from
any other civilization investigators
consider a possible natural explanation
for the phenomenon could it be a bizarre
ice formation caused by powerful
Antarctic winds that could katabatic
winds and they can form these features
called Suzuki equivalent of dunes over
snow sastra gr sharp wave-like ridges in
the snow surface that run parallel to
the direction of the wind they can form
highly unusual shapes but rarely those
visible in the image we are probably not
looking at sister Guinness image because
the feature here is circular and not
long and linear like the general pattern
of sister games there's another force of
nature caused by ice melt in Antarctica
that might explain the shape of this
feature
if it was a natural process that
explained this feature my first clue
would be those dark splotches I would
say the dawn packages are surface melt
that surface melting tends to Pont and
form what are called super glacial lakes
the surface of these lakes can refreeze
leaving a pool of liquid water under the
ice if that pond drains out it will
leave a void underneath the ice which
could then collapse inward and the
structure that you see here you can
almost imagine a circular pond that has
collapsed inward and created these
cracks as the ice could collapse in and
it's a punch effect collapsing ice could
conceivably create similar shapes on a
thinly covered pond but in Antarctica
the ice sheets can be incredibly thick
three and a half miles of ice covers
most vantika ice sheets miles deep are
unlikely to collapse we can learn a lot
from satellite imagery but without
actually going there we're not going to
be able to figure out exactly what this
depression is
you